Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have,
case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when he is soul is taken away, Allah
says he's going to say what? Send me
back to do Hajj, umrah, salah, fasting,
what? No, sodaka. Brothers and sisters,
Ayera is getting thousands of shahadas
monthly, yearly. Hundreds of thousands
of people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training duat. Brothers and sisters, do
you want the part of that? That goes on
forever. This is how Islam has spread
around the world, brothers and sisters.
Carry on this legacy of the prophetam
inshallah by donating whatever amount
inshallah and support right now
inshallah. Enjoy the video. Asalam
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
you guys in I came across this video on
Instagram and alhamdulillah I found it
quite powerful because at first I was
thinking is this is this guy squaring up
to Hamzat um this other Muslim fighter
and obviously I don't like seeing Muslim
to Muslim fighting going on etc. Um and
the sports there in it's it's not
primitive. It's haram. Listen makes it
very clear. Uh you know I know some men
out there are selective uh when it comes
to you know certain things pertaining to
sisters it's haram haram but when it
comes to sports uh people go about it
and I'll be honest with you I've been
guilty of it as well and we need to
really tell ourselves hold on a second.
Is this permissible? It is not it's not
a permissible sport to do especially
advertising marketing etc. So here's a
video guys inshallah of av
confront a Lebanese fighter after sparks
sparked chaos by throwing punches during
a event. Here's what went and let's see
what his issue was cuz I thought it's
something to do with personal or the way
he behaved etc. It was a little bit
something deeper than that and I need to
admire Hamzat for what he done.
>> It's got to be.
So when I saw this obviously I was like
first I don't know if the other fight is
a Muslim. If it is I'll be honest with
you Muslim fight another Muslim and then
for you know MMA where there's half
naked girls gambling betting all this
kind of stuff and even Khabib said it's
not an impossible sport. So let's make
that categorically clear. So here I was
like yo why is why is um um approaching
him like is it personal beef? Is it
something to do? Like I was just
thinking to myself um you know you know
fight to say Allah abbar alhamdulillah
they say stuff like that um which it
doesn't sometimes belong in the arena
they're doing so here is what actually
was the issue so let's go in
done guys Done.
>> Anthony, where Anthony?
>> So, let's just give some context into
this. So, you might must be thinking
it's nothing personal. It's this maybe
the way he behaved. No, it wasn't. So,
let's read. Inshallah. Oh, here's what
the caption said. Okay. It says, "The
words Allahbar are sacred." So the issue
that Hamzad had with the brother was
obviously besides the those things
happened you know it's happened with
this fight it wasn't pretended that cuz
obviously Hamzat will be a hypocrite
because he's points where push somebody
or something like that or they've pushed
him they've had this it happens
sometimes people do it just to cause
more drama ticket sales etc that wasn't
it it's the fact that he said Allahbar
Allah is the greatest this is something
that we use to glorify God Almighty and
people use it in the wrong ways which we
know you know they do they do attacks
suicide attacks etc whatever for that
matter and they chant the name of God
Almighty it's something so sacred that
used to preserving life. In the Quran,
Allah says, "If you save one soul, is as
if he saved the whole of humanity." And
there are maniacs who go and kill
innocent people and child, God is
greatest. Yes, he's the greatest and you
will end up in hellfire for killing
innocent people. Now, he had an issue
with him saying Allahbar, he said, don't
say Allahbar. So, I'm just going to read
what was said here. Okay? The words
Allahbarb are sacred. They are not to be
used in anger, in um in chaos, or in
places and situations when our behavior
is unislamic. to lose control and
aggressively behave like a psychopath
and then shall is wrong. This is not how
the name of Allah is honored and it's
not what pleases Allah. Our brothers
was clearly telling him that you should
not say Allahbar in anger in an in an
anger situation like this and he was
absolutely right. These words should
come from humility, calmness,
reflection, prayer, gratitude and
submission, not from rage, ego or
uncontrolled emotions. We represent
Islam wherever we like it or not. Our
actions, manners and character must
reflect the beauty of the deen
especially in the public. So the prophet
also says the strong is the person is
not the one who can overcome the other
by strength but the one who controls
himself in anger. So this is very
important because at the end of the day
brothers and sisters in the battle of
brother this was chanted. It was chanted
for the sake of Allah. It wasn't chanted
for glory to oneself or better. No he
has to be used in his proper place. Now
you're doing a sport that is not
permissible. It's haram. On top of that
you get into some kind of altercation
with another Muslim. Again this is
wrong. you know hitting another a
Muslim's face anyone's face for that
matter is not permissible and then for
subhan Allah you shout you shout
Allahbar for what bro this behavior that
you're doing was ill manners and we
understand your your your you know hated
and he pushed you whatever it is for
that matter so Hamzat advised him and
gave him the sea and said look listen
this is not the place especially what
you're doing so I admire that because
you know why because this is what our
religion calls to we have to enjoin the
good and forbidden evil wherever it is
be it a man or woman this is not a man
or woman issue that's why when we see
evil We need to call it out because
Allah tells us that he has made us the
greatest nation. Why? Because of this
very reason. He has made us a region
because reason religion great ummah
because we enjoying good and forbid
evil. And that's why myself I've been
personally attacked many people when you
call out an evil of someone going out
there and telling people to divorce
divorce divorce or you've got menus men
who are sims who are sexually
objectifying their wives and get them to
jiggle in or men who are coming on
social media and saying oh I'll put my
hands on my wife. they will everyone has
to be warned against including me. So
this is why it is so important that when
he saw that action he said no I have to
advise you in public because what you've
done is a public matter he could have
done in private. So alhamdulillah I I
admire brotherhabib and even the sports
that they're in is not permissible that
they he went and saw and said listen
don't shall it's not a good look you're
kicking shouting breaking things and
saying Allahbar okay the enemies of
Islam can use this so I admire that nia
and then Allah says in the Quran the uh
that advice for indeed advice benefits a
believer okay and the prophetam said the
dean is nsia and we should never ever
stop this no matter who comes and you
guys know I've been personally attacked
my family members have been targeted
my wife, my kids, etc. Wallah, it brings
nothing but sweetness to what I do
because now I know I'm paying cost to an
extent where my family members have been
dragged into. I'm getting death threats.
But let me tell you something. Never
ever inshallah tala we will stop this
cause because we are never going to let
the bully of the radical feminists. Yes.
All these red pill red pillars or the
farright Zionist ever going to stop our
cause because we fear. Okay. Let our
wealth, our health, our life, our death,
our families, our children be sacrificed
for this cause of Allah subhana wa tala
inshallah and may Allah accept it from
us. It's not a big word and I ask Allah
not to test me with it. But inshallah I
have the im that everything is
sacrificed in the cause of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala to make his calam not me not
was nobody was not a respect a dirt and
I'm not saying out of humbleness let our
lives our wealth our health our death be
be for the sake of Allah subhana wa tala
that we speak the truth wherever it is
no matter what fear happens and I salute
for advising this brother may Allah
bless and guide us all inshallah till
next time asalam alaikum take care
Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when he is sold is taken away, Allah
says he's going to say what? Send me
back to do Hajj, omrah, salah, fasting.
What? No sodak. Brothers and sisters,
aya is getting thousands of shahadas
monthly, yearly. Hundreds of thousands
of people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training duat. Brothers and sisters, do
you want a part of that that goes on
forever? This is how Islam has spread
around the world. Brothers and sisters,
carry on this legacy of the prophetam
inshallah by donating whatever amount
inshallah and support ayra right now
inshallah. Enjoy the